so uh what part of Jacksonville are you
from I'm from Jacksonville Florida North
side of Jacksonville Dunns Avenue okay
so I like
I don't know how to really explain it's
just the north side [ __ ] but the north
side of Jacksonville biggest foot though
yeah like it's a lot of neighborhoods
just on the North side specifically
right that's it's just that [ __ ] just
big as [ __ ] Jacksonville some people
would say is uh
at the moment one of the more
violent places uh in terms of just like
if we're just talking about hip-hop at
all like I just feel like it's kind of
like a it's hot a lot of beef going on a
lot of back and forth a lot of people
wrapped up in [ __ ] why do you think the
temperature in Jacksonville is
is that
um
honestly
yeah oh this bro this [ __ ] that [ __ ]
been going on for Generations like this
ain't something that just started though
right like how everybody making it seem
only reason it's just starting because
they don't put because now the
spotlight's there yeah the music
Spotlight down there so not everybody
really starting to see it's nothing new
though
ain't nothing
yeah I think like obviously uh some of
the um
more prevalent artists from the city uh
shout out to well sure first of all
shout out to YK Osiris who's from yeah
he's from Jacksonville a lot of people
don't know that he was a lot of people
money but he's very talented young man
and he's from Duvall
little Duvall's from Jacksonville yeah
it's a lot of it's crazy though like
when you think about it Ace you know we
keep going you got Papa [ __ ] spinner
bins wobble with the chopper
spinner bins is like in court right now
right yeah bro right now
it's crazy yeah yeah
are you cool with those guys yeah
they're my brothers okay
I just don't know man because I don't
ask you for the wrong guy listen man I'm
trying to stay out of it man my name is
Bennett and I'm not in it you know what
I'm saying
[ __ ] I just know that y'all y'all
Jacksonville [ __ ] dissed
differently yeah I don't I ain't gonna
lie to I don't really see the difference
between like I drill music and other
people drill me it's a lot more
disrespectful I don't really see it
though oh I see it New York
I don't know man that New York name
dropped just like us though
I mean listen let's be fair
I haven't seen somebody in New York go
shoot a video at someone's gravestone or
do a video on a golf course
talking about who they smoked
it's very flagrant it's flagrant levels
of disrespect in Jacksonville where I'm
just like what the [ __ ] is going on over
there with these kids [ __ ] there's like
no there's like no law no code no like
boundaries that they won't pass like
this [ __ ] is by the way I've interviewed
both of them Ace fully off interview
both of them and I try to preach the
same thing to both of them like yo One
Day You're Gonna you're gonna grow up
and you're gonna regret this [ __ ] like
like [ __ ] you know what I'm saying like
and you're cool I know you're cool with
Ace in those guys and they're super nice
guys you know I've had Ace on my show a
few times he's a sweet dude
um for you like are you
like are you trying to disc like like do
you try to stay out of the mix when it
comes to worrying about local local
problems with people obviously your
career is on a high trajectory right now
um honestly like
I don't the type of person I am but I
don't say [ __ ] to people I ain't no [ __ ]
starter but once you start it right
you're you're responding everything
ended
so not everything I'm gonna do
everything no you're not going to do
everything
but musically yes
I just like well I ain't saying you know
no I'm saying I'm just saying like
situations period because like I don't
go around looking for trouble like yes
you see me on the internet tweaking out
I got a reason like I had a valid reason
but people don't understand that though
do you feel like
you could ever get to a point
where you can be the bigger man and just
be like hey I'm doing better than this
person that's why they doing this I'ma
just leave it alone yeah for sure for
sure I um
really I did it
but I got my pride getting my I let them
pride get in the way Pride's gonna get
you [ __ ] up man yeah probably get you
[ __ ] up for sure for sure for sure
[ __ ]
but honestly
I feel like when when you become like an
adult officially it's not when you're 18
not when you're 20. it's when you put
your when you realize that pride is your
enemy bro that Pride [ __ ] will have you
doing a lot of [ __ ] that you should not
be doing all because you think
it makes you look weak or whatever the
[ __ ] it is you know what I'm saying like
the real gangster [ __ ] is to be like
I'm not even gonna get my energy into
that [ __ ] keep it moving
yeah
but you know what I gotta feed you I
gotta give you some my my mushroom
gummies you're gonna eat a whole bag of
those and you come on the other side
you'll be like man up [ __ ] [ __ ] it bro
no more none of this [ __ ]
nah I'm like I ain't gonna lie to like I
really don't care about the like the
[ __ ] that's going on in Jacksonville
yeah cause like I don't stay there
anymore you you removed yourself from
the situation yeah I don't understand
Florida at all
just all where are you at
um
um I ain't in Florida it's a different
state way different state yeah yeah
that's fair yeah I don't really
I don't really be in tune and really be
caring about that [ __ ] no more like
people can't even piss me off like that
no more like I get pissed off by some
whole other [ __ ] that's not related to
the to some Street [ __ ] going on smart
man yeah so like and then that's what
I've been like that's another thing like
I don't proved I can bubble in music
without without the op killing music
yeah I got a whole album called who am I
yeah I did good you feel me so like I
don't really too much care for that [ __ ]
no more I feel like too A lot of these
labels and people are like they really
take advantage of
I I just man to me the Jacksonville [ __ ]
is so crazy like if I was a label I'd be
like we can't put this out man like we
can't put this up yeah I mean numbers
don't Lotto yeah but like at what cost
yeah you know what I'm saying